hey folks tim ferriss here and i have a
question
from a viewer i'm going to answer and
explore that i don't think i've really
explored before and that is
living environment considerations how do
you think about your living environment
what do you look for in a home and how
do you decorate
okay so this is going to be a
combination
of like one part feng shui
one part self therapy one part prepper
so that is the cocktail that you're
going to receive
let me touch on a few different aspects
the first
is safety so if i'm thinking about my
living environment my home
i want it to feel and be safe and other
pieces beauty which i'll come back to
and elegance to a lesser extent which
just means simplicity
so wabi-sabi for poets philosophers and
artists i believe is the name of a book
that kind of reflects how i think about
some of that and also imperfection in
the house
which we probably won't explore too
deeply on the safety front
i like to be generally 10 to 15 minutes
travel time via car to downtown my
preference is not to be
in the actual center of downtown because
if there are
protests riots or any type
of other catastrophe your options may be
severely limited
however i do like to have an office
downtown in some capacity because that
offers
oftentimes more reliable grid meaning
power
water etc and it also offers you
a second backup option if for whatever
reason you need to leave your primary so
the primary would be 10 to 15 minutes
drive time from downtown whatever
downtown happens to be
and then within 30 minutes drive time to
an airport
ideally with international capabilities
and that has been the case for me for
the last
20 years or so in the home or in
structures at the home the garage and so
on i view it as mandatory
to have at least two weeks of backup
water supply
that could be in the form of containers
of water which i have but also could be
say a big berkey filter of some type
through which you can run water from say
your pool
depending on the various chemicals and
treatments that are used
for your pool or from a hot tub or
something like that
okay but suffice to say if you don't
have at least two weeks of water
i view that as as foolish as not wearing
your seatbelt
on the highway or not having a fire
extinguisher
in your kitchen it's easy insurance it's
inexpensive
it's been proven time and time again to
me through personal experience how
valuable this is
hurricane sandy personal experience
power outages in san francisco
due to all sorts of issues the freeze in
austin texas most recently
which brings me to another suggestion
that is some type of backup
power in my case i have two generators
because i dislike single points of
failure
that can act as backup for full home
power these are fueled by natural gas so
if
needed with some basic maintenance they
could power the entire home
for several weeks that most recently
put my household in a very good position
to help
other people because we had put on our
oxygen mask first
and we had both water and power and
space to spare so this is not only for
yourself if you want to be in a position
to help other people or
those in your community these are basic
precautions okay that's not what i think
the person asking the question intended
me to provide but without safety the
home means nothing
it's all window dressing so number one
is safety needs to feel safe
next there are aesthetic considerations
so if possible i like to have indoor
outdoor
areas and there are ways to
manufacture that if you have large
windows
floor ceiling windows of different types
it's not available to everyone i
understand that but in an ideal world
that would be one component another
would be an open floor plan with
multiple levels
let me explain what i mean by that so i
really like for instance in the kitchen
in particular
a very horizontally expansive feeling
room with steps up it could be even a
single step
and by creating these levels even in say
a 200 square foot space that would be
pretty small
but you get the idea in a kitchen you
could make the kitchen feel twice as
large
by having even a minor level upon which
you then have a separate seating area
for dinner at the
dinner table and this gets into
architecture and
i would encourage people to check out
something called biophilic
design which is a really
interesting rabbit hole to get into bio
right biological philic
leaning towards or liking biophilic
design is worth
exploring green and green
if you want to look at architecture and
design would probably most represent
my aesthetic which is a combination of
let's just call it japanese and northern
californian kind of big sur sln type
architecture so that blend i find and
extremely calming which brings me to the
next point and that is
most items in my house whether it's
artwork
or furniture or otherwise is
selected with the intention to produce a
particular emotional
state and i think about emotional state
a lot because
for most of my life i suffered from
extreme bouts and extended bouts of
depression
so i'm acutely aware of the things that
affect my mood
and inside if you were to look at say my
artwork
and decoration there are a few
consistent points one is there's a lot
of green i have a lot of plants
and i try to ensure that these plants
are
relatively easy to take care of which
isn't that hard to do but
green and plants have an enormous impact
then i have a lot of photography related
to artwork
that includes animals that includes
well humans humans are part of nature
and also scenic shots landscapes
that could be milford sound in new
zealand which i've had a panoramic photo
of for
20 plus years and it's traveled with me
everywhere it could be shots of the
oregon coast
or the rainforests in oregon
photographs of wolves of bears of
jaguars all over the house and then
i have nostalgic pieces that remind me
of one of
the most impactful periods of my life
which was a year in japan as an exchange
student so i have
japanese calligraphy i have a handful of
japanese
artifacts not many but saddles of all
things if you want to see a fun video
search my name and something called
yabusame
that's japanese horseback archery
i'll leave that for you guys to explore
and really that summarizes
the general aesthetic the general
sentiment the general feeling that i
want to cultivate
which is one of safety it's one of being
part of nature not
apart from nature and
uh also a feeling of
not being alone and that just came to
mind because if you walk to my house
you'll notice
almost all of the photographs of humans
have the eyes
looking out so every time you look at
that piece of artwork you feel as though
you're face to face
and connecting with another human being
so those are a few
of the ways in which i make a house feel
like
a home for me
you